look when my party grows up and I would
have the honor of becoming prime minister of the Netherlands
then I am
for all Dutch people leave that
without klaas and for everyone what you believe
whatever your background is
but that doesn't mean
that you should not be able to point
at the dangers of some ideologists and biologies
I have lost my own freedom for 20 years
and I'm not the only one
because of susceptible that come from 1 ideology
who does not accept
that you criticize something and there
I warn you
but I think the people who are in the Netherlands
and they are going to keep our rules
that they participate as much as everyone else